allô c'est papa on va bientôt me laisser
sortir
un petit peu plus généreux
pour le temps qu'il me reste à vivre ça
me plairait bien de le passer avec toi
je vais accepter mais à une condition tu
me perds loyer
[Musique]
éternité que j'étais pas venu ici c'est
un dépôts
[Musique]
le souffre-douleur je vais t'emmener
quelque part on va te montrer quelques
bonnes techniques de combat
tu crois que c'est une bonne idée
[Musique]
sinon quoi devient pas jouer les foutu
et retentez n'est pas un
[Applaudissements]
pas le droit de m'empêcher de le voir tu
crois c'est ce qu'on va voir
[Musique]
je te promets que plus jamais je ne
laisserai sans me prendre à toi
je suis que rien de pouvoir rattraper ni
ce que j'étais ni ce que j'ai fait mais
quand même moi d'être ton père juste une
fois
pourquoi tu es allé en prison
parce que tu y es allé plusieurs fois
tellement de fois que je compte plus